one of the biggest things that you're  known for is women i don't like  traveling the world with women i think  it's one of the most frustrating things  a man can possibly do with a chick it's  all i need food i need water where's my  stuff my case is 55 kilo oh i forgot  this foundation i need to find this  foundation it's horrible i do agree if i  haven't eaten i'm not good yeah so women  are effectively children  we're just different to men we're not  children a child couldn't sit here and  have this conversation with you women  have to be monitored and maintained and  maintenanced effectively like a child  would when it comes to not like a child  yeah same exactly the same delay  show